we've now reached the second release of
the Android Q beta program
q as enhancements to privacy and
security and of course there's a lot of
great stuff for developers let's start
with how Q builds on top of androids
strong privacy protections Android Q
enhances runtime permission requests to
give users more control over when apps
can get location when Android q prompts
users to give the app the location
permission it now enables users to allow
the permission only while the app is in
use in the foreground allow the
permission always or to deny the
permission check out the developer guide
for details that how to adapt your app
for this new permission model Android Q
continues the work in previous releases
to limit access to non resettable device
identifiers including device IMEI and
serial number the MAC address of the
device is now randomized by default when
connected to different Wi-Fi networks
most of our API is for scanning networks
already require the course location
permission but in Android q for
Bluetooth cellular and Wi-Fi were
increasing the protection around those
api's by requiring the fine location
permission instead finally Android Q
continues the process of limiting access
to non SDK internal interfaces you can
turn on an office for testing purposes
and tell Android to enable access but
print log messages Android Q adds new
support for foldable devices allowing
multiple apps to be in this resume state
at the same time most apps won't have to
address this change but we've added a
top resumed activity callback that
should be used to open and close
exclusive devices such as the camera
we've also changed how the resizable
activity manifest attribute works in Q
if an app sets resizable activity equals
false along with the fixed orientation
or aspect ratio display changes will
cause the app to be letterboxed and
resized to maintain the aspect ratio you
can use the canary release of Android
studio 3.5 to create a foldable virtual
device with a beta to image the emulator
gives you on-screen controls to trigger
fold unfold change orientation and quick
actions also an Android q' apps can
request a dynamic depth image supported
devices will return a JPEG
with embedded XMP metadata related to
depth related elements and a depth and
competence map the existing direct share
feature gives users the power to share
content to a specific contact with
another app but the implementation adds
latency when displaying the share UI in
Android queue developers can publish
share targets in advance allowing the
share UI to load much more quickly these
work similarly to app shortcuts so we've
expanded the shortcut info API to make
integrating both features easier and
added the shared target Android X
library to allow apps to leverage the
new functionality while still supporting
pre queue devices using direct share
Android queue adds platform support for
notification bubbles circular icons that
represent app content various apps have
used system alert windows to build
similar interactions and were excited to
standardize on a straightforward
implementation for developers that
provides consistent interactions for
users bubbles are built on top of
androids notification system to provide
a familiar and easy-to-use API for
developers with a bubble being a type of
notification to bubble a notification
you need to make sure the notification
channel allows bubble notifications and
then call set bubble metadata to add
bubble metadata within the metadata you
provide the bubble icon along with the
activity to display as bubble content in
queue you can use the Settings panel API
to show key system settings as a
floating panel in the context of your
app a browser could use this API to
display connectivity settings such as
airplane mode Wi-Fi and mobile data
users can then manage these settings
without leaving the app we've done a
bunch in Android Q to allow for higher
performance apps for example apps can
create a Wi-Fi lock to ask the platform
to optimize Wi-Fi around low latency
Android q also adds support for the
high-performance Vulcan 1.1 graphics API
and makes 1.1 a requirement for all
64-bit devices running q and higher
Android q contains a preview of a
standard updatable OpenGL driver for all
devices built on Vulcan called angle you
can enable angle for all apps or for
individual
apps in developer options the neural
networks API has been updated to version
1.2 adding 60 new ops including Arg max
Arg min quantized LST M laying the
foundation for accelerating a wider
range of models such as those for object
detection and image segmentation Android
Q now allows apps to pull the current
thermal status of the device and
register for a callback when the thermal
status changes this can help real-time
applications such as games reduce their
workload in response to an overheating
device we've also added a native MIDI
API in the NDK this API allows MIDI data
to be retrieved inside an audio callback
using a non-blocking thread enabling low
latency processing of MIDI messages
Google Play is now delivering
cloud-based profiles along with apks
these are anonymized aggregate art
profiles that let art pre-compile parts
of your app even before it's run giving
a significant jumpstart to the overall
optimization process cloud-based
profiles benefit all apps and they're
already available to devices running
Android P and higher and there's so much
more like support for the a v1 video
codec improvements from managing IOT
devices over Wi-Fi passive support for
biometric prompt and TLS 1.3 for
information on how to install the
Android Q beta check out the links in
the description enjoy Android q learn
about the new features and api's you can
use in your apps please leave us
feedback on the beta on the Android Q
beta developer site you'll find release
notes and support resources for
reporting issues
[Music]